and we're going to get started on our
markers unleashed from charting to
automation. You know, I know uh many of
you have been asking me uh to to get
together with Pablo and and do something
together so you guys can see, you know,
how you could automate, you know, not
just order flow, but you know, any other
charts that you have, you know, any
other sort of signals that you use. And
you know, I'm not sure if some of you
are familiar with markers already. I
know some of you guys uh use it and and
you want to know uh better ways to use
it. And you know, hopefully today you'll
you'll see how easy it is to use
markers. It's got a lot of flexibility.
It's not necessarily just about,
you know, taking a, you know, like like
an indicator and plugging it into
markers. You could actually do um you
know, other things with markers. And you
know, just a just a heads up. You know,
if you got any questions, be sure to put
them in the chat.
And you know, I'll try my best to get to
them today. I'm going to try and keep
this around just under an hour. I don't
want to keep you guys on all day long. I
mean, we got another call tomorrow um in
our group as well as uh as Friday. And
you know depending on sort of the
feedback that I get um I might just have
a special uh call not including Pablo um
either you know over the weekend or
maybe on on Monday as well sort of to go
over your questions. All right so again
you know just a brief disclaimer
obviously you know we're all adults here
in the room um you know trading involves
risk right and only risk capital should
be used for trading. So, and you know,
automated trading comes in in many
different shapes and forms, right?
Simply put, automated trading means you
use software or algorithms to execute
trades. You know, it's funny because I
see a lot of people talk about, oh, the
algorithm out there, like there's some
big mysterious algorithm, but it's
really just a term um you know, fancy
term for uh computerized trading and uh
you know, you use it to execute your
trades on your behalf based on your
predefined rules and conditions. you
know, and it what it does is it sort of
frees you up from sitting at your
computer manually clicking buy and sell,
right? The system does it for you when
certain criteria are met. You know, I I
have certain criteria. It's not just
excuse me about orderflow conditions
being met. You know, I like to I always
talk about uh follow through order flow,
right? Where where there's orderflow
coming in that sort of gives uh credence
to what you're seeing in the order flow.
That's what I call follow-up order flow.
So, you know, you might be a good fit
for automated trading if one, you have a
tested strategy.
I'm sorry, just coughing all of a sudden
because you know when it comes to
automated trading you know I don't
necessarily recommend it for everybody
but uh you know there are sort of
offshoots what we call what I call
semi-automatic
um you know where you're going to be
able to manage a trade but you know at
the start of it you need a strategy
right you need to have a system in place
so to speak I I like using the term
system because you know that's sort of a
derogatory
term in in trading because you hear
people say, "I I've got a system, right?
I'm going to sell you a system." And
it's not really about a system, but
rather a strategy on trading. And you
know, a good strategy becomes more
consistent. The bad strategy doesn't.
Bad strategies lose money. So, if you
already have rules that work when you
trade manually, automation can help you
execute them more consistently.
Because, you know, that's a problem that
I see with with traders is, you know,
maybe they got a method of trading and
it just can't, you know, they can't turn
it around. You know, they're still
losing money, but it's like, you know
what? I'm back testing this and it's
making money. I just wish I had a way I
could automate this to take the trades
for me. And, you know, that's something
that markers can do.
The second part is, you know, maybe you
struggle with emotional discipline,
right? you find yourself holding losers
too long, hoping they'll bounce back or
selling winners too early out of fear.
Um, you know, automated systems don't
have emotions, right? You always say,
"Oh, you know, everyone says, "I've got
no emotions when it comes to trading."
Well, really, a computer has no
emotions. Humans have emotions. Even
people that say they have no emotions.
Um, you know, the computer will follow
the rules every single time. For many
traders, this emotional removal is
gamechanging. Um, you know, it's just
it's just something that traders, all
traders struggle with, right? Being able
to put their emotions in check. And it's
something that doesn't come easy. It
takes a lot of training as a trader, a
lot of developing as a trader to remove
your emotions. And you know, the easiest
way to do it is have
an automation in place that that takes
the trades for you, okay? or maybe that
gets out of the trades for you because
that that's where traders struggle. And
it's not just in trading that emotions
get in the way. You know, sports,
relationships, um once emotions take
over, things veer off to the side and it
it's usually um not pretty, right? We
we've all seen, you know, athletes lose
their emotions. You know, football
players throw their helmet, soccer
player kick the ball out of the play, um
you know, tennis player break their
racket. And the same thing with traders,
you know, you you lose your emotion. You
you I I don't want to say people punch
the screen, but uh you know, definitely
traders have their own um case of
emotions on way to handle bad trades and
you know, automation either fully
automated or even semi-automated
uh helps you with that emotional
discipline.
Maybe you can't watch the markets
constantly. Maybe you have a full-time
job or you trade international markets
in different time zones, right? I always
um you know I always get messages from
people saying, "Hey, how can I uh I got
a full-time job. Can I trade?" Well, of
course you can. There there's markets
that trade at night. Um there's markets
that trade, you know, basically 24
hours. And you know, if you work a 9
to5, maybe you wake up at 5 in the
morning and you can get a couple hours
trading before you got to get ready to
go to work. Um being automated means you
never miss an opportunity because you're
in a meeting or asleep. Now again,
that's fully automated. I know there are
traders out there that like to have
things fully automated. I I take it a
little step back. You know, again, I
talk about semi-automated,
meaning, you know, I I still like to sit
in front of the computer and watch the
trade as it's developing.
Automated trading may be good for you if
you trade multiple strategies or markets
simultaneously. You know, humans, you
can only focus on one or two things at
once, right? We all like to think we're
great multitaskers, but at the end of
the day, you know, when you start
spreading yourself too thin, um, things
start falling through the cracks. Trades
get missed and an automated system can
monitor dozens of opportunities across
different assets at the same time. So,
you know, you could be looking at
Japanese yen as well as well, not
literally looking at, but you could, you
know, have uh, you automate a system
trading Japanese yen and and one that's
trading uh, copper, right? or NACA. So
you could have, you know, or even crypto
to a certain extent.
You know, maybe you value back testing
and data, right? If you're analytical
and want to test your ideas against
historical data before risking real
money, automation platforms include
powerful back testing tools. And you can
do that with markers, right? You can run
um, you know, sort of historical testing
to see how well your system did. Okay?
And you know, I know a question that
comes up a lot is uh you know, stress on
your PC. Now,
everybody's got different PC specs,
right? Some have the latest ones. Others
have, you know, something that's maybe a
couple years old and and I I know
there's some that have some that are,
you know, going back to 20 uh
2016, 2017, 2018, right? They're still
using those older computers. And you
know with order flow
uh indicators generally you know I like
to use tick replay. Pablo will show you
you know you can use markers without
tick replay. I mean you could you could
test it you know test your system and
then just run forward without tick
replay being run right tick replay for
an indicator like say uh imbalancer is
so that you can plot the historical
instances of the indicator appearing.
But if you go forward, right, you don't
necessarily need to have tick replay
going on as the signals will appear. All
right? So, you know, that can help speed
up your
basically your I say speed up your
trading, but rather um you know, not
lighten up the load, so to speak, on
your um computer on your trading
computer. Now, just really briefly,
there's two different ways to use
automated trading. fully automated trade
entry and exit partially automated,
which is why I prefer trade entry and
you manage the trade and decide when to
exit. I mean, you're still going to have
your ATM in there, right? Your
take-profit and your stop-loss. But
again, you know, I I'm a big believer in
watching the order flow, being an
orderflow trader, that if things change
in the order flow, I want to get out. I
don't need to get stopped out to get out
of a trade. If things change, I'll get
get out early. Right? It's that's
simple. So again, if you're hands-on,
you could you could use markers as
semi-automated. You can still get out of
a trade at any point, right? So let me
ask you, would you rather get stopped
out at your full amount or stopped out
at half or just be happy to scratch the
trade? You know, and that's the
difference between automated trading and
semi-automated trading. And
you know, to me, this is an important
topic because, you know, there are
traders that that's the way they think.
is like the trade is either going to go
to my
target or I'm going to get stopped out.
Why? You don't need to put yourself in
that position. Just let you know if
you're reading the order flow and things
change. You get out, take a profit, take
a smaller loss. Doesn't have to go to
your there's going to be plenty of
opportunity at another time. Okay. And
before I turn it over to Pablo, just
really quick, right? Remember with
automation, you need to identify the
setups first, right? I mean, you have to
have a solid trade
strategy for getting into a trade as
well as getting out of a trade. Okay?
You can't be
tell the system to do nothing, right? It
needs rules. Okay? So, it needs a reason
to buy or sell. For example, you know,
maybe delta increasing by a certain
percentage over x number of bars. You
need to give it something um tangible.
so that you can
give it the rules, right? I mean, you
have to have an idea already. You could
use markers to back test it. I don't
think we'll have time to get into that
today, but um you know, I'm going to do
a a followup to show you how to set up
markers, how to download the data, run
it back on historical data, uh to sort
of test out what what you want to do.
But, uh, for now, what I'm going to do
is I'm I'm going to turn it over to, uh,
Pablo and, you know, let him show you
guys how you can use markers
for your trading. So, Pablo, I'm going
to turn it over to you and I'm going to
mute myself.
What? work. Can I show my screen?
>> Okay, looks good. I see your screen.
Whoops.
>> But which one?
>> Oh, there we go. This one says the
indicator store. Yeah.
>> Okay, this is the correct one,
>> right?
>> Hello everyone. Hello Mike. Thank you
for your invite.
And let me start by presenting me for
those who don't know uh I am Pablo from
the indicator store. One of my products
is markers a tool that lets you automate
any signal and also create your own your
signals. No, but let's start by
one
of the common questions. Okay, you have
an orderflow signal like this is the
order flows toolbox. No, and you can see
I only have one indicator. You need to
remember the settings of your indicator
because you need to copy
an instance of the same indicator into
markers because
the the usual way no uh to automate the
signal is okay no problem. I go to
marker copy.
Marker copy. I choose a name. For
example, I am going to copy the long
signals loans. And then on input series,
I select the indicator
order flows toolbox. So okay, I select
the the indicator and then I select all
the corresponding parameters because if
I don't set the same parameters then
they are not going to match. I remember
that what I have is um
I really don't remember. Sorry, let let
me check. Uh it was
you you sent me those settings. Uh
enable thin prints
with a three and a one. And there was
also another thing selected uh this one
the PC.
So on the copy I select the same
parameters.
thin prints with a three and a one. And
the the other was uh
open PC
with 25.
Okay.
Now the the indicator that we want to
copy
works at each tick. I guess
something that we always need to check
if what I copy is working at each tick.
Then I need to copy at each tick.
And just for checking I want to show a a
signal that it should overlap. Okay. So
maybe I made a mistake on the
parameters. So what I copy is not what I
see. So let's add a cyan
big dot. Okay. When I click on okay,
this chart is h it has um tick replay.
So you know it takes some some time
then you need to have tick replay.
So we need to wait. Okay. And there you
have it. This the signal of the
indicator and the copied signal. And you
can see that they match. Now to do the
same for the shorts, an easy way to
avoid any problem
because you you know there are a lot of
parameters. So they they need to be the
same. So you can select, right click and
copy, click on another place, right
click and paste.
So now we have two instances of the same
marker. Copy, copying the same signal.
So I I save some time by not needing to
to set all the parameters but of of
course I need to change the name
and also change the plot.
So step number one I can change the
label here instead of markers copy this
is the logs. Okay, just for visual
uh the long the most important is the
variable longs and I am going to use
this as a fast signal. Okay,
then
the other instance
the most important is the name of the
variable shorts. Okay, this is a fast
signal. Okay. Also the visual part
instead of marker copy
shorts
and we can see we get an update. H but
the most important what I copy
is already set. All the parameters were
already set because I did a copy and
paste but I need to change to the other
plot cell signal. Okay.
And also we can change the color of the
dot. H it should match with those
triangles.
So let's use um
gold.
Okay.
Now we need to wait again
because now we have the the classic
order flows the copied version of the
longs and the copied version of the
shorts. That means we are calculating
three times the the usual time that it
takes to calculate this. Now we can see
the the order flow has calculated. Now
we have the long signal and the short
signal. Now we are ready. Usually when
you are copying an indicator that don't
require h tick replay this is fast. So
now we can add markers on this chart.
But on this case
my suggestion if you have an indicator
like this is add another chart new chart
same instrument
in this case is standard and any time
frame it doesn't care it doesn't matters
uh because it is just for execution.
So on this chart I
execute the orders but this chart has no
take replay. Okay. So it is a quick uh
chart. It has a fast response. And what
I want to do is add markers
where I want to automate the fast
signals that I created on this chart.
The names were longs
and shorts.
Okay, very simple.
The variables are global. So this is the
reason because you cannot use the same
variable on another chart.
Now you need to select an ATM, your
preferred ATM.
Click on the ATM button. Select an
account and you can see that it is not
valid because the SIM account is not
present on this feed. I am connected to
uh playback. Okay.
So click on the account and now it is
ready. it is ready to execute all the
longs, all the shorts in fully automatic
mode. Fully automatic means all the
signals are executed. If you if you for
example know looking at the picture, if
you want to go long because we may have
a possible dole bottom, then I only want
the following long. So I select
semi-automatic. That means if I have a
short signal, it will be ignored because
the short button is off. H if I get a
long signal, it will be executed using
this ATM and the button will turn off
because this is semi-automatic.
Okay. And this chart is really fast. I
can even configure a filter. For
example, let's say I want to filter
those signals, all these signals. No,
with I don't know the slope of a line.
That's very
I I don't want to make the video too
long, but you can enable a filter and
also you can enable exit conditions.
Okay,
now I can continue adding more because
this chart is slow. But I I don't need
to to to edit that that chart. I I I
only need to edit this adding more and
more things like for example filter
conditions, other signals. Let me show
you now on the step number
one. This is what what we did recently.
Okay. The coped signals and here the
execution. This chart has a tick replay.
This chart. No. Now if I continue.
Okay. Now I have two charts
with different uh setups and the two
charts are using uh tick replay. So if I
touch anything on this chart, we need to
wait for it to calculate not only the
indicator but also the copied version of
the longs and the copied version of the
short. Okay, remember three times the
usual time that you need. But you don't
need to touch this chart anymore or this
chart anymore. You can work on this one.
Now you can you you may say okay how can
you uh separate or distinguish which is
a signal for each one which are the
order flows and which are the delta
scalper. This chart is a delta scalper.
Very simple.
When you copy a signal, if you are not
using different names, for example, I am
using longs and on the other chat, I was
also using longs, just use a different
link ID. Okay. And now on these markers
I have the order flows using one looking
at longs and shorts and the delta
scalper using two also looking at longs
and shorts. Okay. And each one is using
a different ATM. Okay.
It can be a different or not account.
That's your decision. Each one
may or not have a filters, extra
conditions.
For example, a classic is I want this
signal at no more than five bars than
this other signal. We can do all on this
chart
and
we can continue.
And here we have the three H setups that
Mike shared with with me. The order
flows volume shift, the order flows
toolbox and the delta scalper. All of
them are doing a copy of the long and
the short signal with the same name. The
only difference is the link ID. Okay,
here
the link ID I guess it is uh three. No,
yes, three.
And the names are always longs and
shorts. So I have full control over the
main chart where you can see it is not
taking anything to calculate because it
is just a standard chart. H I have the
name for each one of the templates and
also maybe we want to back test what I
have here. The only problem is the t the
time it takes to calculate the
historical. Okay, but no problem. Let's
do an example.
I going to close all the other
workspace. So having the minimum of
workspace and also the minimum of charts
is a good idea to speed up the process
because currently I only need
this chart for execution
and these three charts to calculate each
one of the signals. Okay,
I don't need the other workspace
and I guess this one is empty. Yes,
nothing here. Okay,
now here is a a tip that you can use.
Let's say that you are on playback and
you want to replay all that we see on
today's chart at maximum speed.
Something that you can do is right
clicking on your playback toolbar. I am
assuming that you have already
downloaded the replay data and you are
ready to play. That means the the data
feed is working. Okay. Now you can
select play the current day
and now you can see it is selected and
then go to and select the current day
and the current time where I am now I am
at 4:30. So I want to re to reach to the
exact same place as we are right now but
h playing back everything
all these settings. Okay. So I can I can
click on okay. That means it it needs to
reload the data on these three charts
and we can see how it is uh doing. We
can see that this the this this chart is
ready. The chart without the replay.
This also is ready. This is also ready.
Now we are waiting for the
this one.
And when the charts are ready then we
need to wait for the calculation. You
can see that all of them are calculating
calculating
and this has not started yet.
Okay.
Okay. If my computer crashes don't worry
I I will create the video and share with
all of you. Usually I play back only one
setup at a time. So
maybe I am going too far from this
because we are playing back three really
complicated trade setups all together.
Okay, now we can see the three charts
are ready and now we need to calculate
uh the three of them. Okay, we can see
this indicator is ready, not the copy.
Okay, we need the copy to finish.
And on the other two charts, everything
is uh waiting.
By the way, this only happens on tick
replay charts at a refresh, not on real
time. Okay, on real time uh there is no
the tick replay is not used on real
time. So it only happens when you did
something because all the historical
needs to be recalculated.
In the meantime, you have time to set
the correct settings. No, if you want to
execute all the longs, all the shorts
because this chart is uh ready to be
Okay, now we can see that the dots are
ready. So this chart is uh no longer
waiting. Okay. So chart number one has
the indicator, the copy of the longs,
the copy of the shorts. Now we need the
other two. Sorry for the delay. I was
not expecting to
this to be so slow.
Okay. It looks
it is ready and we can see
all.
Okay, it finished. Okay, the the as you
can see the real time execution is fast.
The only problem is to wait the
historical. Now your question is okay
which one work better or not? Well, we
can see here on the main chart
the last trade and the daily trade. No
uh all the three setups were working
fine. And also uh you can open a trade
performance.
Here we can see the net result and you
can filter and the importance is if you
use a different ATM for each um setup
then you can filter by ATM. For example,
this one at the top. Uh oh, let's leave
only one the 10 versus 20. 10 contracts
uh versus 20. It made 375.
I guess it is this one. The volume
shift. Okay. Now, if you select the
second,
then this is the best. Oh, the order
flow toolbox. Okay. And then the third
one.
Uh it was all winners 350 350 is one the
delta scalper. If you want a detail
you can look at the trace individual
trace one by one
and you can see all of them were
winners. Instead
this one uh was one loser and here
it had only one loser. very useful.
Anyway, I suggest doing one by one
because maybe you notice something that
maybe you can increase the target h use
a different trailing instead. If you try
all together, it's a mess.
By the way, you you saw it is more or
less not so complicated, but it takes
some time. Okay. So, I have ready to use
templates. So, you don't need to to do
all of these. I have templates for the
three setups in this format. Okay. The
you only need two charts. One for the
indicator, another for the execution.
And on the execution chart, you have the
option to add extra conditions like for
example filtering by time, by volume, by
the slope of a line, by whatever you
want. Okay?
If you want more info about me, I can
say that we have a live h YouTube so you
can see all my template, not not
orderflow templates. And this this may
be something that I may include in the
future. But currently you can see my
best uh templates working live all days.
This is the URL of my YouTube. Also you
can access my free chat room. This is
the link to my chat room. Very simple
TIS chat.
And this is my chat room where I was
today commenting that the order for
order flow was about to begin. Erh you
can contact me here. H my info is this
and here is my email.
I don't know if there is any question
because I I don't see the questions.
mic, but I am doing
>> Yeah, there's uh let me see here. There
are some questions. I'm just looking at
them right now. Let me uh
scroll back up to the top here. Just
give me a sec.
Um there's a question from uh George.
Can you adjust when the trade is entered
like on bar close or does it
automatically trigger once triggered? Um
so,
okay. I I think the question is um can
you adjust when the trade is entered?
I mean if if you're talking about your
Yeah. Once you're into the trade, you
can you can move your take profit and
your stop um
that you can do. I
>> Yeah, I I guess I understand the
question. The the the idea is what I
explained today is at each tick. So
really I don't know at which moment
those signals are painted. If the
signals are painted in the middle of the
bar, they are executed at the middle of
the bar. Okay. If you don't want to do
that, you have the option to wait for
the bar close. And also there are some
signals, I don't know if this is the
case, but there are some signals that
they are painted and deleted. Painted
and deleted. In that case, maybe you
want to wait for the bar to close and
check if the signal is still present and
then enter at bar close. This is also
possible.
>> Yeah. Right. It's uh actually that's
that's one of the things that
um when I first started using markers is
before
like with uh a lot of our order flow
tools, we have what we call the trade
entry signal um which would wait until
the signal bar is closed and you have
the follow through order flow before the
signal prints and once it prints it
won't uh disappear. If you're
not using what we call the trade entry
signal, um, and the signal appears as
the bar is still trading, it can appear,
disappear, appear, disappear. Um, then
once the bar closes, it is there. um
with markers, right? That's that was one
of the things that because I've been
with markers for a long time now. And
you know, I wanted a a system or a tool
that would help me enter into a trade. I
got to have a signal. And this was years
ago like for example Delta Scalper
before we used the trade entry signal
where okay I I got the signal but I want
to wait for the bar to close and the
next bar um or two to open and move in
that direction and then get me into the
trade. So yeah, you can do that with uh
with markers. Um so let's see here. I
got uh
uh there's another question that's
unrelated from Chris about uh can you
okay you need needs a new let me see
here sorry here I'm just reading these
questions
okay Chris uh yeah I'll reset your ID um
he's asking how do we filter Delta
Sculper for example with MACD that one
Valentine Um,
let me see. I'm just cut writing this
down. I'm going to I'm probably going to
do a follow-up to this uh presentation
because I wanted to see what some of
these questions are so that I could
either make a video or or do it live for
you guys because he's asking how do you
use filter delta scalper for example
using um another indicator.
I'm going to save that one for for
later. Um there's another question from
Mata asks how many filters can be used
at once in one chart. Pablo
>> it is unlimited.
>> Okay.
>> Because the the filter is something like
let me show you know because I am not
using filters here. But if I enable a
filter, h enable filters, I can say,
okay, the close is greater than the open
and also the volume on the current bar
is greater than 1,000
and also uh this or that etc. Yeah, you
can write all the string that you want
uh using all the the copied variable
from all the charts. So it is unlimited.
>> Okay. Okay. Um Yolanda is asking about
how to get the templates uh that you
mentioned there for like uh Delta
Scalper Toolbox.
>> Contact contact me to my email.
>> Okay.
>> My email is Pabloindicatorstore.com.
>> All right. Let me just uh I'm going to
put that in the chat there for you guys
here. look at indicators.com.
Okay.
Um,
okay. Mata says, uh, he means like, uh,
going back to the filter
or the filter question,
uh, how do, uh, where is it? Can we use
something like VWAP as a filter or like
a 200 period EMA?
>> Anything and you can you let me show you
something very simple so you you have an
idea. Let's say I I want to to look at
the direction of a line for example say
I don't know let me copy a line. I I
need to copy whatever I want to use. No.
So I am going to copy I don't know my
HMA my preferred HMA is
an HMA 200 maybe
HMA 200 okay
and let me draw it in color uh red
in a thick line.
Okay. So now I have this line. You can
see okay I want to go long and you can
see that there are several trace
executed there. But maybe I want to
filter when the line is going up or also
when the price is over the line. You
have several options. No. Uh option
number one I want to execute longs only.
For example for the delta scalper. No,
on the delta scalper I enable the
filter.
Enable the filter and I want to and this
is a default filter.
But for example, I want um the close of
the current bar greater than the HMA on
the current bar for longs. No. uh the
close is an internal variable is the
price on the current bar and the HMA is
the variable that I copied here.
Okay,
so I want okay the close over the HMA
and the for the shorts the close below
the HMA. Okay,
now you can see filter is on and I have
a weight it means it need to let me
advance so it can calculate. Okay,
hmma zero not phone. Okay, because HMA
was copied with a different link ID.
This is a classic mistake.
The Delta Scalper Delta Scalper is using
the link ID number two and I copied with
the link ID number one. So I need to use
the same link ID. Okay. Now
longs are disabled because the line is
going down and also the price is below
the so only shorts are enabled because
the close is below the line. Another
possible option is I want to look at the
slope of the line. Is the line going up?
Is I I want um how can I know if a line
is going up? Let me let me show you the
two options. You can use a logic
where I I need to use the same link ID
and the close is greater than the HMA
when this is true. Okay, this histogram
is showing when the close is greater
than the HMA. But take a look at this
part. The slope of the HMA is going
down.
So how can I know the slope of the HMA?
Another logic
which is the formula for knowing if a
line is going up or down. Same link ID.
The HMA on the current bar is greater
than the HMA one variable. It means it
is going up. Okay.
And now this is the place where this
line is going up. That means I can use
this logic as a filter. Okay. On delta
scalper.
Instead of this I can use this for longs
and the opposite for shorts. Okay. In
the same way I can copy the MACD and I
can say okay for longs I want the MACD
greater than something or for shorts I
want the MACD less than something. And
you can also do a complex like for
example I want the MACD greater than
something and also that the HMA going up
and also that the price is over the HMA
etc.
Make sense?
Yeah, it's it's pretty flexible. I mean,
you could add, you know, sort of as many
rules as you want and,
you know, filters, you know, that that's
the whole point of of uh, you know,
having something automated because, you
know, if it's not automated, you can
miss it if you're watching the screen u
manually. So it's it's you know it it
has a lot of flexibility on what you can
do rather than just
you know have an indicator and say take
all longs take all shorts. You could
even take it a step further like he's
just showing you there with the HMA. um
you know only take shorts when prices
below the HMA or only take longs when
you're above the HMA which sort of gets
into like you know what you're asking
there with uh you know the 200 EMA but
um yeah I mean you can combine them you
could have you know
different
or different rules I guess you know I
mean I know there's some people say oh
you you know somebody one time is trying
to sell a system where it's like you
just trade when price is below the fifth
you the 25, the 50, the 100, the 200
EMA. Um, you know, it it's something
like that you could easily automate um
with with markers. Um, let me see here.
There's another
question.
Uh, trying to find it here.
Okay, we did that one. Got the templates
one.
Okay, George asked, "This is sort of an
unrelated question to markers. What's
the difference between all these
orderflow indicators? Well, they just
read different, you know, like Delta
Sculper reads certain things in the
Delta V shift reads um
volume and volatility uh toolboxes a bit
like uh Norflow's trader without the
footprint chart. It'll give you the
signals. It allows you to combine um you
know sort of the different nuances of
orderflow. Actually back in uh March of
this year, I believe it was uh Pablo and
I we did a presentation on using markers
with the toolbox. It's it's a great uh
combination because with toolbox which
differs from say orderflow trader you
which is the footprint chart you know on
orderflow trader on the footprint chart
it'll show you like say when you have a
thin print and when you have a um open
point of control like like he just
showed you on on this toolbox chart
with
workflows trader. It's just going to
identify when that appears, you know,
when the thin print appears as well as
when the open point of control appears.
But if you just have a thin print, it's
still going to signal it. If you have
just a open point of control, but no
thin print, it's going to signal it.
Whereas the toolbox sort of combines
them and it will only show you signals
where you have a thin print plus the
open point of control. Okay? So the
toolbox sort of takes the order flows
trader a step further and allows you to
combine sort of the different tools from
the orderflows trader uh to generate a
trade signal. Then what you do is you um
use markers once you sort of have your
setup uh you could use markers to even
well to trade it for you. But like I
said you could even uh refine it a bit
further. you know, if you know, you're
using something like a VWAP tool or
you're using, you know, any other tool
that you want to use as a filter, you
could add that in. Okay. Um, let's go
dig through a couple more questions.
Uh,
so now there are only two indicators,
delta SC, others, nine more. No, we
still have them, but uh, you know,
obviously there's a time limitation. You
know, actually what my plan is, my goal
is is to sort of build out a a template
database for anyone that has Delta Scalp
or anyone that has Wall Shift, you know,
so they could have a sort of a
ready-made template. The only thing that
sort of keeps me back from creating a
database like that is because, you know,
I don't want traders coming in thinking
that, oh, this is the only setup. This
is the only way to use it, right? You
know, with with my indicators, you know,
everyone trades different market,
different chart type. Um, you know, I
know a lot of traders now are moving on
to uh RV charts, etc. And, you know, I
don't want it to become, well, Mike says
you have to use Delta Scalper on a one
minute chart in this. No, you you really
want to expand it, but but at least by
having a template um you know, it's
something to build a starting point
from. Okay. But definitely don't think
that um you know that when you get a
template for an indicator that that's
the only one that you have to use. Um,
you know, I always say you got to find
the way to use the tools that suits your
own trading, right? Because like I said,
everyone looks at different markets.
Everyone looks at different time frames
or chart types, um, rangebased charts or
timebased chart or tickbased chart or
volume based chart. Um, there's so many
different charts available that
sometimes it's hard for me
to have templates to cover every single
different chart type, right? It's just
not possible. um you know simply because
there's there just I don't want to say
it's unlimited but it's a lot but anyway
that that's something that I plan to
build out over the next uh few months is
sort of a a template template database
and and there are people out there that
do sell templates actually for markers
already uh predefined. Um Johnny asks
will this uh seminar be recorded? Yeah,
you'll have access to this so you could
watch it again. Um,
okay. Yolanda, Yolanda's asking for more
more example, exit examples if you have
time. Um, well, yolanda, I'm going to
write down your question. I'm going to
cover that again. I'm going to do a
followup with this. Um, don't
necessarily need Pablo on there for
that, but I'll show you how, um, you
know, I use it uh, in terms of exiting
and stuff like that. Um so
George asks is there
do you have a list of commands in their
meaning such as close
um bracket zero bracket or high
do you have like a I don't want to say
glossery or something like that um for
those I'm not sure
yes it is everything in the on the chat
room we have an an online manual
with all the comments and also we have
tech support on the chat room.
>> Okay. Yeah, he's got like a discord chat
um that you guys could go in and and
join and ask questions as well. Um
Philip says, uh yeah, the real
recording. Philip
Mata asks, "What happens if I lose uh
internet connection?" Well, obviously if
you lose internet connection,
your charts not going to be updated. Um
what will happen to markers, Pablo?
Let's just stop.
>> My s my suggestion is h try to have a
VPS.
>> What I I I was showing on my live
YouTube you you can watch it all all
days. It is working on a VPS.
>> Right. Right. Yeah. Um you know that
that's that's a that's a good
suggestion. um especially for traders
that have you know sort of unstable
uh connections or you know even if they
they travel um it's something that sort
of solves a lot of problems a lot of
headaches you know cuz you could log in
to the VPS you know from anywhere in the
world um you don't have to worry about
your connection to the broker to the
exchange cuz it's uh gen you know these
VPS servers actually sit pretty close to
the the actual exchange server. So,
they're pretty reliable and a bit
faster, especially if you're trading
automation.
You know, you want to have uh as low
latency as possible and having a VP.
>> And also in in my opinion, the the
importance of the isolation of your
trading with your computer. Imagine that
currently uh my trading is working on a
BPS. So, I can use the computer for the
presentation and nothing happens. All
right.
Yeah. Yeah. And you know, sometimes it's
it's it's almost like uh the setup of
the VPS is probably better than some of
our our computers at home that we're
running Ninja Trader on. Um and it seems
slow and you get on a VPS that's got
better specs than your than your PC.
It's just going to run faster. Um let's
see here.
Uh I'm just looking at question. Do you
have
Well, Mata asks about uh targets for
target ticks in gold 6E and crude. We'll
talk about that when when I do a
followup um on this because that's kind
of a specific question and again, you
know, targets are based off of the chart
you're trading. You know, sort of the
time frame that you're looking at um
etc. you know, I mean, some traders have
very tight targets, some have very wide
targets as well as stops. So, but
anyway, guys, I'm going to wrap it up
because it's coming up on uh 1 hour
already. I don't want to keep you guys
on all day. It's it's Wednesday and I'm
sure I know a few of you guys uh have to
pick up your kids at school. Um, so
again, you know, automation is a tool.
It's not magic, right? It amplifies what
you give it. Good strategy plus
automation equals consistent results. No
strategy plus automation equals
consistent losses.
Um, I always recommend start small,
scale thoughtfully. Don't automate
everything all at once. Start with one,
right? Prove it works, then expand. Stay
involved. This isn't set and forget,
especially, you know, when you're just
getting started. Now, I know there are
some traders that use markers. They will
go to sleep. They have faith in things
being executed. Um, and hey, more power
to them. I I just I know that, you know,
I have seen firms I've had friends that
worked for, um, you know, legitimate
HFTs where the HFT blew up and,
you know, it lost millions of dollars.
You know, everyone had to get laid off
and everything. That's why I'm always a
big believer in staying involved. Don't
just, oh, this is set and forget. I want
to set it and go watch uh you know a
movie for 5 hours or binge on on
Netflix. You keep in mind you know your
money's at risk. You kind of want to uh
manage it. You know successful automated
trading requires monitoring, learning
and adaptation. Now
Pablo
and myself, well I got a deal from
Pablo. So, I'm going to give you guys a
opportunity to get markers at a
discount, right? Normally Pablo sells
them for$450 a license.
Give it to you today.
Oh, sorry. He sells it for 600. Give it
to you today for 450. So, that's uh
that's a nice discount like what 25% or
something. Go to this link
strategic.com/markers.
Right. It's not my order flows one. It's
strategic traders. I'll put it in the
chat. I'll send you guys the link out
later um with the replay as well because
and I know it's something you know a
presentation like this you do want to
watch again um so you could fully
appreciate what markers is able to do
because
you know really this is where
not not the future is but um being able
to automate your trading system right
because people always ask me what's your
favorite trade setup well I have several
Right? And being able to automate them
helps manage what's taking place in the
market, right? Cuz you know, at the end
of the day, right, you you've seen me,
I've done live trading workshops, etc.
And generally, I'll watch one or two
markets with you have markers, right?
You could have a screen like what Pablo
live streams every day. He's got I don't
know how many uh different markets
you're showing on there, like nine or 12
um different markets. You know, with
markers, you're able to do that, right?
You you can have multiple markets open.
You just have markers running on each
market. Then you don't have to worry
about missing the trade because markers
is already programmed to take the trade
based on your set of rules. Okay? Then
you know once it gets into the trade
obviously you're going to hear it um you
know Ninja Trader obviously makes the
sound you know
what so that you can just watch the
trade manage it from there. So, it gives
you the ability to uh
monitor and trade different markets.
Okay. So, anyway guys, you know, I I'll
wrap it up. You know, later tonight I'm
going to once the replay gets rendered,
I'll send you guys the replay and the
link for the special deal. And again,
I'm going to do a follow-up one because
there's some of these questions is it's
literally kind of specific. I think um
me making a video or doing a an
additional session,
you know, could help you understand
more. Um and and going through the
actual setup from scratch is really
simple. Once you get it, you know,
anytime you use a new software, there is
a learning curve. There's just no way
around it, right? Because you're just
not familiar with the software and and
how to set it up. And you know, I'll
probably do a session. I'm thinking of
Monday, um, where I could sort of hold
you guys by the hand and show you
as I do it live, um, how to set it up.
All right, so thanks everyone for coming
out. Thanks Pablo again for your time.
Um, I I really appreciate it. And, you
know, traders, I think, you know, if you
haven't got markers yet, it's just
something you definitely need in your
toolbox. So, thanks everyone for coming
out and again, thanks Pablo for uh your
time today. So, have a great rest of
your day everyone.
>> See you. Byebye.
>> Byebye.